now we all know that you love desserts
yeah we do a little yogurt parfait with
some macerating of fruits so the first
thing I'd like you to do is I take a
tablespoon of icy sugar dust that over
the fruits good now that's perfect dummy
thank you zest the orange over the
fruits what's gonna happen now it's
gonna start to sort of marinate and
there was some buzz in there that'll
make it really flavor some fresh puzzle
in and then for you to give that little
mix up I'll squeeze some fresh orange
juice in there nice and gently okay how
gorgeous are those berries look now okay
we just leave them does marinate okay
and that's what we call macerated
berries now for the mango sundae -
mangoes in please I love my days
nice now they're naturally sweet mouth
now how fresh does that smell
know you'd love art yeah so you're gonna
put these together so nice little dollop
of manga at the bottom nice and slowly
once each glass has a layer of mango
puree at the bottom spoon over a layer
thick natural yogurt and alternate until
the glass is full of them
now yummy there you get your berries you
see the berries on top it tastes so
fresh but now they'll be marinated and
the berries have been slightly macerated
and then finally look your icing sugar
just tap on top they look just beautiful
now they sit in the fridge to get nice
and chilled okay
so I take three and promise not to
sneeze and you take one open the fridge
door good job